Este es el epicentro actual del
conflicto en Ucrania la ciudad de bacmut
en el donbad que lleva varios meses bajo
el fuego de la artillería rusa aquí en
la línea del frente las calles están
desiertas cientos de familias ucranianas
viven enclaustradas en sótanos con sus
hijos que apenas ven ya la luz del día
gleep de 14 años es uno de ellos Este
joven adolescente que nunca ha salido de
badmud dice que quiere quedarse a pesar
de la inseguridad permanente
me gusta eso me gusta estar aquí no
tengo nada que temer lo que me gustaría
es dar un paseo al aire libre
Y si tuviera al menos un amigo Sería más
divertido
casi todos los niños abandonaron la
ciudad con sus familias los que se
quedaron arriesgando sus vidas se apiñan
en refugios como este instalado un poco
más allá en el sótano de una escuela
para gregory de 13 años es el mismo
ritual diario un viaje de vuelta para
almorzar en casa y volver a esconderse
aquí
antes venía aquí con mi madre pero ahora
vengo con mi abuela vengo aquí a cargar
mi teléfono cuando estoy en casa a veces
leo libros
el trayecto desde el lugar familiar
hasta este Refugio es muy peligroso como
nos cuenta Hanna la hermana de grigori
dos civiles han muerto en los últimos
días en el camino
vivimos sin agua electricidad
calefacción ni internet la mayoría de la
gente no tiene trabajo y se limita a
sobrevivir
la gente está siendo asesinada todos los
días como de costumbre
niños sometidos a tres crónico que
pueden desarrollar graves trastornos
mentales y cognitivos a largo plazo